in a previous video we've introduced
ourselves to the idea of federalism in
the united states at a high level you
could view it as a contract between a
national government and the states of
which it is made but you could also view
it as a layered form of government where
you have your local government and then
layered on top of that your state
government and then layered on top of
that your national government often
referred to as the federal government
and we looked at the example of a
layered cake but have said that over the
course of american history the
layers have gotten more and more mixed
more like a marbled cake
and it's been mixed more in the favor of
the national or the federal government
even though certain powers were
historically more associated with the
states as we will see there are several
levers that the federal government has
used in order to extend its power into
the domain of what used to be associated
with primarily the states so one is the
notion of categorical grants so these
are grants for a specific purpose where
the federal government says hey states
we're going to give you some money but
you've got to use this money in exactly
the way that we're telling you now to be
clear not all grants are categorical
grants you have things like block grants
where the federal government can give a
grant to a state and say hey use this to
generally improve the safety of your
citizens that would still give a lot of
leeway to states but in categorical
grants it's very specific in terms of
how the states are to use that money
even if historically it was something
where the states had the powers so an
example of this would be the federal
program the special supplemental
nutrition assistance program for women
infants and children or wic
and to get a idea of how prescriptive it
is here is an outline of the program on
the usda website a federal government
agency
and if we go down here you can even see
things like income requirements and
there'll be income eligibility
guidelines these are set by the federal
government not by the states
along those lines you also have mandates
so a mandate is the federal government
tying funding to one thing
based on state compliance with another
thing
for example the national minimum
drinking age act which was passed in
1984 ties federal highway funds to
states raising their minimum drinking
age to 21.
and i had direct experience with this
act when i was growing up in louisiana
louisiana decided not to comply by the
national minimum drinking age act so the
drinking age was 18 but because they
didn't comply they weren't getting as
much federal funding for highways and
the highways weren't as good as in other
states so even though the drinking age
is something that might be considered a
state power the federal government was
able to exercise a lot of influence on
most states by tying what the federal
government wanted to highway funds
now outside of these examples of the
federal government tying state funds to
the states doing what the federal
government wants
the federal government has also made use
of the u.s constitution in order to
broaden its powers in particular the
commerce clause article 1 section 8 you
might remember that's the part where
they say the congress shall have power
and then they list a bunch of powers but
one of them the commerce clause is to
regulate commerce with foreign nations
and among the several states and with
the indian tribes and the key part of
the commerce clause is among
the several states over the course of
american history this ability to
regulate interstate commerce commerce
between states the federal government
has used that to justify regulations and
laws that focus on issues that may at
first be perceived as a state power
but use the argument that it affects
interstate commerce in order to regulate
it and as you can imagine when you have
free-flowing commerce between states you
have the same currency you don't have
tariffs between states many things that
you would traditionally view as the
power of the state one could argue would
have some influence on interstate
commerce
one notable example of this would be
federal drug laws where a state could
decide to say legalize marijuana but the
federal government can make it pretty
difficult by regulating how is that
marijuana transported or where does the
cash for that marijuana get deposited
does it get deposited in a bank that has
associations with the federal reserve
that needs to transfer that money across
state lines so the interstate commerce
clause has more influence on state
affairs than you might initially think